Is privacy looked at differently in Silicon Valley than in the rest of...
No, Silicon Valley is not monolithic.
We've always had a very different view of privacy than some of our colleagues in the Valley.
We take privacy extremely seriously.
As an example, we worry a lot about location in phones.
And we worry that some 14-year-old is gonna get stalked...
...and something terrible is gonna happen because of our phone.
And so as an example, before any app can get location data,...
...we don't make it a rule that they have to put up a panel and ask...
...because they might not follow that rule.
They call our location services and we put up the panel...
...saying, "This app wants to use your location data, is that okay with you?"
Every time they wanna use it.
And we do a lot of things like that...
...to ensure that people understand what these apps are doing.
That's one of the reasons we have the curated app store.
We have rejected a lot of apps that wanna take a lot of your personal data...
...and suck it up into the cloud, a lot.
A lot of people in the Valley think we're really old-fashioned about this.
And maybe we are, but we worry about stuff like this.
But aren't you also going to be moving more into cloud-based things?
Are we gonna be moving more into cloud-based things?
Sure.
Doesn't that inevitably...
No, privacy means people know what they're signing up for in plain English and repeatedly.
That's what it means.
I'm an optimist, I believe people are smart...
...and some people want to share more data than other people do.
Ask them.
Ask them every time.
Make them tell you to stop asking them if they get tired of your asking them.
Let them know precisely what you're gonna do with their data.